now here's one thing i don't know if you
guys know veer was an actor like was a
comic first but then
was a bollywood actor was in a movie
called delhi belly which was a big movie
in 2010
is bollywood crazy or what it's the
biggest industry in the world yeah
that's why
it's nine films a weekend like nobody
makes movies like we do this is
so for you
really costs like cheap it's cheap but
like what i love is like for years
everybody was like you know bollywood
movies are too long and they're
unrealistic and you have like ridiculous
costumes and now every movie is a
[ __ ] marvel movie which is three
hours long
realistic costumes where somebody's
avenging a father's death and jumping
off a [ __ ] scene yeah yeah like
marvel is just bollywood yeah that's all
it is yeah or maybe vice versa yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think marvel's been around
since like the 40s right not making
movies movies though like marvel movies
are like 10 years old maybe yeah marvel
movies yeah this this iteration of
marvel movies that we're seeing it's
just bollywood without the songs
it's three hours long it's all fight
scenes that are ridiculous now
yeah but they don't say shadow khan got
super powers that's just how he operates
flipping over 18 wheelies you know what
i mean so that is different but what to
me to have
bollywood bruh
there's two indians that you'll push
back on you now oh yeah yeah like that
two indians that's this special yeah
yeah no come on man marvel is is copying
bollywood yeah yes how so it's bollywood
with capes that's it
they all have capes i love this dog
wait al
give some pushback you're very familiar
with bollywood i haven't seen a single
dance routine in a marvel song
yeah we don't do the dancing dude
spiderman
our superheroes don't have time to dance
we're saving the [ __ ] world there's
no time to hop around and [ __ ] maybe the
world wouldn't be in danger if you guys
dance more necessary
how do we let him in not backing down
i will in three weeks when my visa
expires
wait a minute is that how y'all see our
[ __ ]
because this is american arrogance we
think well i mean it is called bollywood
you're naming it after hollywood yeah so
we don't like that
y'all call that [ __ ] bollywood respect
the goats i feel like you guys finally
caught up to what our movies are about
say again i feel like you guys finally
got to try to copy off your copied us
look in language your movies they speak
like 26 different languages right but
majority hindi exactly
exactly dude in india yeah
most people go and see a movie like this
is their one thing that they get to do
each week right so yeah like you got
your wife and your kids and you go out
and you see one movie yeah and that's
like your entertainment for the entire
week if you show that guy spotlight he's
gonna [ __ ] kill himself that week
right so it needs to be like escapist
and huge and big and cathartic and just
an out-of-body experience and you guys
finally caught up to what that's what
movies is supposed to be that's why you
go to the theater you think that we just
figured out escapism and family
absolutely
yeah we never escaped before no yeah i
mean never had fantasy no but like so
far your escapism has been the news
right that's
just uh
that's where you get your fiction i'm
just saying yes yes it is fiction but i
i don't feel like it's escapism news is
like not to be fair you can't insult
american news that's true yeah yeah why
is your news fun it's it's uh
government controls
one guy's news
youtube indian youtuber he's [ __ ]
great did you see
tgi tgif no that's different
indian youtuber and he does it in
english and he also does it in hindi and
this guy's [ __ ] awesome i should
everything is just china sucks and
everything i like that every headline is
like uh uh modi emasculates gigi ping on
the global stage and i'm like let's
[ __ ] go it's indian alex jones that's
the guy yeah
i've not seen it pfi global sounds like
a hedge fund that steals money yeah yeah
but yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah say something about that did you
guys invent hedge funds too
how are you defensive about hedge funds
like that anything americans here hedge
funds what america and it's all good
[Applause]